I want to start by thanking everyone for
being here at a comedy show after such a
depressing weekend
I want to thank you for that was really
I never thought I'd say thank God it's
Monday yeah just so glad today if this
news keeps piling up but today you
probably saw this President Trump made a
speech denouncing neo-nazis and the KKK
but people were upset because he waited
48 hours to do it
yeah well that's what took so long Trump
said I watched Fox News so I didn't know
anything happened snowing at the Country
Club seemed that upset right just it's
all war on Christmas yeah
this weekend President Trump told the
country we have to love each other
that's what he said yeah yeah he did he
said that he liked to love each other
then he said you know until the younger
hotter country comes along
[Applause]
while on a tour of Latin America Mike
Pence described Venezuela as quote
sliding into dictatorship yeah been said
and I'm here to learn sometimes
sometimes people half laughs and they
half get scared
[Music]
well this'll cheer you up I think we're
gonna be in good hands soon Kid Rock is
considering running for Senate in
Michigan that's right kid rock
Michigan but he may not be allowed to
use his stage name
Kid Rock now Kid Rock might be forced to
use his Christian name Deez Nuts
[Applause]
the the hackers here what this the
hackers who hacked into HBO leaked some
storylines for the upcoming season of
Curb Your Enthusiasm yeah now I hate to
ruin it for you but apparently this
season Larry is gonna do something
antisocial that will end up backfiring
ya know what's the point of even
watching oh boy yeah forget it he's
gonna be really irritating yeah a 16
year old Wichita High School students 16
year old high school student is running
for governor of Kansas yeah the
teenagers two campaign promises are to
address health care and get a second
base with Ashley in trigonometry
he's gonna
you